paramedics like caitlyn have dedicated
their lives to saving others
so it seems unbelievable that during a
global health crisis
they should have to deal with abuse and
assault from the very people they're
trying to help
i attended a male on shift had a head
injury
he was really aggressive towards us as a
crew and he spat on me
which landed on my face and went in my
eye i
after this had to go to hospital have my
eye irrigated with water
and also have make sure i update my
vaccinations to make sure that i didn't
catch any
fluid-borne viruses to make sure that i
was safe
um it just made me feel really i felt
quite disgusted in myself i felt really
dirty
sky news can reveal that during the
covid crisis ambulance workers have been
subjected to hundreds of violent attacks
10 of the uk's 13 ambulance services
responded to our freedom of information
request
and according to their figures they've
been over 1600
physical assaults on staff between
january and july
149 sexual assaults were recorded
as well as almost 100 incidents
involving weapons
from firearms and stun guns to razors
and knives
a situation experienced by clinical care
assistant rob
as he dealt with an overdose patient me
and
this patient ended up on the bed
fighting cheek to cheek
had a bruising on my cheek he was
scratching i'd use practice on me
belly in that and he was kicking off and
then all of a sudden he dived straight
between both of us
uh went down to this cupboard we didn't
see it there he was in
uh pulled out a knife about four or five
inches knife
and jumped over that and it wasn't your
like shadow box if he did he tried to
stab us both the gmb
represents more ambulance workers than
any other union
it's backing a proposal for those
sentences to be increased
to two years the other thing that's
happening in the ambulance trusts up and
down the country
is that they're being they're trialing
body cameras
like the police have to wear in order to
try and regulate the behavior of the
people that they're trying to help
i mean it's unthinkable that whilst
facing down a pandemic
whilst dealing with the trauma that the
ambulance staff see on a daily basis
they're also now witness to so many
assaults from the public
the nhs says it'll report anyone who
attacks or abuses their staff
and support any subsequent prosecutions
but with the number of incidents
continuing to rise
many of their staff would like to see
more being done to protect them
as they try to protect us fraser moored
sky news